il était une fois un riche marchand dont
la fille préférée s'appelait bell lors
d'une terrible tempête le marchand
perdit sa fortune et sa famille se
trouve arguments
mais la chance leur sourit à nouveau mes
enfants rené saurez vous des nouvelles
robes du parfum est un pianiste surtout
n'oublie rien et toi qu'est ce que je te
rappelles tu voudrais juste une rose
égaré dans la forêt le marchand fit une
découverte extraordinaire quelqu'un
incroyable teulier ils font presque qui
allait changer la vie des siens
mecha donne deux suffisent fort à qui
est destinée cette rose a plus jeunes de
buffet y
il a dit une vie pour une rose si vous
n'obéissez pas alors en cours à tous au
vert qui deux mois jusqu'au château est
comme moi jusqu'à cette date
je m'appelle je suis venu échanger ma
vie contre celle de mon père ne pense
même pas déraper
la forêt se refermerait en toi
à qui appartient ce château tout ce qui
est ici me partir vous parlez comme
n'importe quel homme c'est assez
décevant
pourrait combler tout étudiant vous vous
drapez dans les périodes un principe
mais vous n'êtes qu'une bête cruel et
solitaire c'est tout de moi rien ça vous
arrange peut-être jamais pensé à notre
passé tu as raison du rond point g
dimanche
les seynois league
servir le château abandonné si je tien
an men tu récupères le reste du trésor
n'était pas sa dette
si vous ne revenez pas
j'en mourrai
c'est marc thoumyre précuits celui des
jeux celle des cieux